hello everyone i'm back for yet another
video um i would have posted one i guess
this is gonna end up coming out tomorrow
but i would have posted one today except
my roommate was home all day and i
really don't feel like getting roasted
for making youtube videos
and getting found out by my other
friends even though that is inevitable
as per always please subscribe to my
channel i'm going to continue to pander
because now we're finally talking about
consensus algorithms and this is when
things get juicy so let's talk about the
first and worst two-phase commit
okay so two-phase commit what is it
two-face commit is a pretty simple
consensus algorithm that is going to
help us solve atomic commit which is
basically allowing us to do distributed
transactions which basically go through
on every node that involves them or they
all get reverted on every node that
involves them so to just kind of explain
that in more detail as far as what
atomic commit is let's say we want a
transaction that has rights to multiple
partitions right so you know i have like
a profile partition
and then you know uh
each of like my um
let's say we're talking about linkedin
each of the job listings is going to be
um put into its own partition and i'm
writing multiple job listings at once
and so they're touching multiple
partitions and i want those changes to
either go through on all the partitions
or be reverted on all the partitions so
in order to do this we basically need
them all to succeed or all to fail and
that's hard to coordinate because
they're not just on a single machine
they're over a network
so why do we need atomic commit i
mentioned one case which was just like a
partition database but in addition to
that if you recall something like global
secondary indexes where
basically every single time you write to
that secondary index the right has to
also
be kept in sync on another node which
holds the relevant part of the secondary
index
that's the case where atomic commit is
super important and in addition if you
want to keep other derived data
consistent um like a data warehouse or a
cache then additionally we need atomic
commit um you know you might even think
about a case where like say
i am going to send an email out every
single time i have this right
and um you know you want it to be the
case that an email is only sent when the
right is successful because otherwise
let's say an email gets sent
the right to the database is not
successful well we have to retry that
right to the database and now we're
going to be sending two emails which is
annoying
okay so let's talk about two-phase
commit basically there are three
components well three components in this
graph that i'm about to show you there's
this concept of the coordinator node and
then there are going to be two database
partitions so two database nodes the
coordinator node is not necessarily its
own computer you know it might just be
software running on one of the database
partitions but effectively the
coordinator node acts as like a single
leader in this sense and so that's why
i'm having it as its own area in the
diagram
okay so let's imagine now that i want to
make a write that has to go to both
partitions so after the database
partitions have kind of like received
the data that they need to write this is
where two-phase commit actually begins
the coordinator node is first going to
send a prepare request to both of the
partitions and the prepare request is
going to be responded to so the
partitions are going to send the result
of that
let's say they both say okay what does
it mean when you say okay it means that
each
of the partitions is going to say i am
ready to actually commit this
transaction as soon as the coordinator
node tells me to do so once a partition
says okay i am prepared to do this
it means that it is saying that no
matter what happens disk failures the
partition just loses power and network
failures eventually it's going to commit
that transaction
so what actually happens after all of
these okays are received by the
coordinator well two things
if not every single partition responds
with an ok what the coordinator is going
to do is send
a result network call to every single
one of the nodes which is going to say
abort and so every single partition is
going to abort the transaction if every
partition basically says okay i'm
prepared to you know commit this no
matter what i don't have any disk issues
no uniqueness constraints no other types
of errors then what the coordinator node
is going to do is take the amalgamation
of all those okays from the prepared and
actually tell all the partitions to go
ahead and commit that transaction
so pretty simple but let's go and
actually explain why this works well for
starters since we have only a single
coordinator node each transaction has a
monotonically increasing unique
transaction id
so what that means is that you know
we don't have to potentially like mix
two transactions up we just you know can
easily identify them and each node is
going to execute its own local
transaction just like
you know a transaction that we've
discussed in the past what this means is
that it has acid properties so
we don't really have to worry about any
concurrency bugs there and in addition
to that we know that
either all of the writes on an
individual node are going to succeed or
fail themselves
okay next when a node responds okay to
the preferred phase this is known as the
commit point it's basically saying we
are going to go ahead and commit this at
some time in the future and we're ready
to do so until we hear the word and
nothing that happens including other
transactions is going to stop that note
from being able to eventually commit
this transaction
okay
furthermore the coordinator node just
for fault tolerance has an internal log
of whether each transaction should be
committed or aborted so let's say the
coordinator node receives word from all
of the the participant nodes this is
like the database it nodes um the
coordinator node receives from all the
participants that they're all good and
prepared to commit this transaction
before it actually goes and tells them
all to commit or abort it's going to put
that in its right ahead log so that if
the coordinator node crashes when it
comes back to power it can go ahead and
make sure that that actually goes
through that adds a little bit of fault
tolerance
um the thing is though there are a few
issues with two phase commit
well first of all is and you know first
of all and kind of the biggest thing is
that it's not fault tolerant
if a partition fails after the prepare
phase the coordinator needs to try
literally forever to reach it let's say
the coordinator wants to hit partition
one but partition one crashes before it
can tell it to commit the transaction
the coordinator is just gonna keep
sending messages over and over and over
until uh to partition one until it comes
back up and can eventually commit that
transaction
well that's bad enough in the sense that
you know you can't really proceed too
much further there i mean i guess you
could start doing some other
transactions the the bigger issue is
actually that um if the coordinator node
fails it's a single point of failure
there's no um
like fault tolerance there
if that goes down everything goes down
no rights can actually be made the
system's completely blocked and the
nodes can't actually you know go and say
like oh okay i know that the coordinator
node is down because you can't know that
it's down it's unclear if it's actually
down or the network connection is just
buggy but in addition to that they can't
abort that transaction locally that
they've already committed if um you know
say like half of the half of the
partitions have committed the
transaction but the other half haven't
because the coordinator node failed
before it could actually tell them to do
so well the issue there
is that
the ones that have already committed the
transaction can't just roll it back
because of the fact
that they don't know that the other
nodes are going to roll back their
transaction there's no like consensus
between them that hey we're actually
going to roll this back the
coordinator's down
so another even further big problem is
that these in doubt nodes so ones that
have already um basically said i'm going
to go ahead and commit this transaction
but the coordinator node then fails on
them they're going to be holding on to
locks for these relevant rows that
they're going to be touching and if you
remember two-phase logging which is kind
of how these databases implement
serializability or the traditional way
that most of them do
what they'll actually do is claim an
exclusive lock on these rows whenever
they want to write and that means that
not only can
other transactions not write to these
rows now it often means that other
transactions can't even read from those
rows so you're really slowing down the
whole system
okay just as a little bit of a
digression or a tangent i'm going to
quickly touch upon heterogeneous versus
database internal transactions because
even though i said so far the two-phase
commit is not that feasible between you
know having to coordinate with every
node over the network and in addition to
that you know just having no fault
tolerance it actually turns out the
two-phase commit has been used in
practice pretty well and the reason for
that is that there's the difference
between these heterogeneous and database
internal transactions
so heterogeneous transactions is
basically two-phase commit but running
on a really basic library called xa or
api rather
that needs to work on basically every
single type of storage system that is
persistent and what that means is that
you can't really make any optimizations
on the hardware because you don't
exactly know
there's no there's no protocol basically
to talk about the locks on certain rows
amongst different types of databases
however
amongst you know let's say one type of
database software
aka a database internal transaction
two-phase commit can actually be really
efficient in the sense that you know you
can actually share more information from
node to node since um you know you can
actually put it in the software itself
for the database and as a result instead
of using something like phase locking
which would be
shutting down all of the nodes
for reads where
a transaction might be grabbing the
locks you could use something like
serializable snapshot isolation which is
an optimistic concurrency control type
and as a result it won't be as blocking
so as you can see in times where you're
not doing xa and instead are using
database internal two-phase commit
transactions that can actually be kind
of feasible
but okay just to quickly summarize um
two-phase commit is basically a protocol
used for distributed atomic transactions
and it's also you know a form of
consensus
where all you're doing is basically
going to all the nodes from one
coordinator node and saying are you guys
ready to commit this transaction and if
they all respond and say yes we can do
that you go ahead and tell them to do so
if one of those nodes that is going to
commit the transaction goes down you
have to keep reaching out to it
indefinitely and if the coordinator node
goes down you're really screwed so as a
result it lacks fault tolerance
in subsequent videos though we're
actually going to talk about much better
consensus algorithms
such as paxos or raft or zab and all of
these are able to
kind of use some sort of fault tolerance
which actually if you remember from
the leaderless replication video has
very similar logic to quorums which is
you use a majority of nodes to determine
consensus instead of having to reach out
to every single node so that way you can
determine
you know what the truth is without
having to have every single node running
okay i hope you guys enjoyed this video
two-phase commit isn't too complicated
however
these next consensus algorithms that
we're going to talk about are
significantly harder to understand and
um as a result of that they're going to
be some pretty long videos and it might
take me a couple days to kind of compile
all that information together and post
about it but i hope this one helps have
a good one guys